well it's a very serious situation on
capitol hill
where we've got an impeachment trial
underway
donald trump's lawyers they call it
absurd and
unconstitutional meanwhile we've got the
prosecution
saying this is the comeuppance for
treacherous donald trump
and the backdrop for all of this is a
country that is deeply
deeply divided this trial will tear this
country apart
perhaps like we have only seen once
before in our history
we are really here because the majority
in the house of representatives
does not want to face donald trump as a
political rival
in the future with this trial you will
open up new and bigger wounds across the
nation
the constitution is a document designed
to protect the rights of the minority
not the rights of the majority
now the charge against donald trump in
the impeachment proceedings
is inciting insurrection and they are
arguing that under the 14th amendment of
the u.s constitution trump is ineligible
for
office because he engaged in inciting
insurrection and this flows from the
events of january
6th um we've heard testimony from what
happened
at this point people are recapping of
the situation where there were five
deaths there were many injuries on
capitol hill as trump supporters
stormed in and penetrated the u.s
capitol congressional staffers
were very afraid for their lives there
was violence that unfolded
and all of this has got the prosecution
at the impeachment trial appealing to
people's emotions and saying there must
be
harsh consequences for trump if that's
not an impeachable offense
then there is no such thing what our
country
experienced that day
is the framers worst nightmare come to
life as one senator said
they could have killed all of us
this cannot be the future of america
we cannot have presidents inciting and
mobilizing mob violence against
our government in our institutions now
these are very serious proceedings with
a very big implications for the country
however if you're looking on it seems
like a rather
theatrical and strange performance
you've got the
recitation of poetry you've got
witnesses
crying and breaking down into tears and
i told my daughter tabitha
i told her how sorry i was and i
promised her that it would not be like
this again
the next time she came back to the
capitol with me
and you know what she said she said dad
i don't want to come back to the capitol
you've got the waving around of mao
zeitung's little red book in order to
make political points
it's all very theatrical very explosive
meanwhile
all across the country millions of
americans who remain
quite divided in the aftermath of an
election
they seem to be watching with lots of
anger gun
sales are up throughout the united
states here's some of what we've heard
from americans
if it keeps heading down the same way
they're going to push people into
another civil war i'm very worried about
this country where it's going
the bad thing it's a bad thing he's out
of office we're going to teach you for
it
is for to remove him from office he's
already been removed
it could get worse and it seems like
every day it does get worse
that's not good for us if half the
country decides to start going and
killing democrats
then you know i don't want to be a
victim
you know and like honestly i've never
thought about that happening
until until this election at some point
there will be a final vote on whether or
not donald trump
is indeed convicted regardless of the
outcome donald trump has certainly made
history he's the only president
in u.s history to have been impeached on
two different
occasions so quite dramatic goings-on
we've got the military all over
washington d.c
we've got the country watching on
television we've got a lot of divisions
74 million americans voted for trump
despite a pretty solid number voting
against him
impeachment proceedings continue even
though donald trump has left
office already and is not the president
the impeachment vote
marches onwards
there's a heavy security presence around
the capitol building where the hearings
are taking place
the area is sealed off by a 2.5 meter
fence and national guard troops are on
patrol
it's part of a major security operation
that has been running since the storming
of the capital by trump supporters on
january the 6th
the pentagon says the troops will stay
there at least until mid-march
and the entire operation will cost
almost half a billion dollars
something that may not impress taxpayers
already suffering
in the coved hit economy with millions
needing government financial support
as a senior advisor for the 2016 trump
presidential campaign told us
democrats have put so much energy into
the process a trial was inevitable
well i think it's also important to
understand in which i think
most americans really don't is that it
is political theater
it's it's a political trial it's not a
criminal trial
and so the this is this is about the
politics
of the individual they have in front of
them which is happens to be
the former president of the united
states we're here because the lens
is clearly political which is we don't
like donald trump
and we don't like what he did we don't
like what he said
while the president probably was an
artful and should probably not have said
some of the things he said
does it really rise to um to
the incitement of violence that
democrats are claiming
this this is all about whether or not
the majority party
which has never really liked donald
trump as we can
all admit to that i mean there's not any
democrat that's going to come out and
say i
i liked donald trump and the donald
trump administration so
there's a lot that they need to um
to unpack uh through this this hearing
but i do think it might
actually lead to a trial um only because
they've spent this much time and energy
and effort
and publicity um and propaganda on it
so if we're not going to go to a trial
then why put the american public through
this when we already know the outcome is
going to be
that he doesn't get impeached
you